please welcome to Star peacocks the
Amber Ruffin show we got her Amber
Ruffin Amber now that's different I
didn't know we had Amber
thank you for being here do you spend a
lot of time on social media not much
maybe 15 20 hours a day and for every
600 cringy racist videos out there there
are one or two cute ones that are
slightly less racist that's a lot of
time that's a lot of races
wow
I've done some curating and I want to
share a few of my favorites from this
past year with you let's look at it yeah
this girl used her social media platform
to show us that even farmers can have
annoying ass co-workers whether it's a
turtle or a tortoise then I would
recommend a manual oh disrespectful yeah
I know you shouldn't today we are going
to be talking about an annual joke
hello Emmanuel you hear me Emmanuel look
at this evening my name is Emmanuel
dammit
does it bother you when certain people
speak to certain animals as if they're
the same and just responsiveness as like
a dog or a person yeah or a person like
that that that thing did not understand
his name no it was Emmanuel he didn't
turn around one time and give the look
of her a million times but he don't know
what it means Emmanuel or he understands
everything she's saying no doesn't give
a [ __ ]
can we recreate it and zoom up close
like well all the way up okay you ready
hey Emmanuel
[Music]
Emmanuel
[Music]
Emmanuel
Emmanuel I said no
in Emmanuel now
[Laughter]
that was a goddamn perfect impression of
a goddamn Goose what was that what
do you eat goose monsters
what you got next Amber this next clip
is very very sweet because no matter how
old you get you're always mom's little
boy
is it because
it's my mom
I'm trying to work right now you know
what they're calling my phone
no traffic cause you got cars behind
them French Bridges oh I know you said
you was working but you've been lying
the last three times
his mom was human Emmanuel that was
human Emmanuel popping up there
oh that was great that's what happened
when you speak English he basically
politely told his mom get the [ __ ] out
the shot right get your stupid ass out
of here I'm right here all right don't
judge that in a lot of aspects of his
life yeah I brought your juice all right
Amber what else you got for us until
this next clip I never knew that the T
and t-ball stands for twerk
hey hey
I'm feeling it ah
[Music]
[Music]
I'm leaving I'm nasty I'm loose I'm
nasty yeah yeah don't let the nasty man
to the plate oh my God what was he
listening to when he was walking out uh
he was listening to the loop Pop That
[ __ ] that was a that was that I popped
that [ __ ] a clear match yeah uh amber
we have to say thank you always we
appreciate you for joining us the world
needs more of you because you provide
needed laughter keep doing you girl we
love you